Speaker 1: OK, so I tweeted about this yesterday
and got some really interesting responses,
so I decided to talk about it today.
I've been self censoring on the program or
censoring myself, as some would say, over
the issue of recent anti-Semitic attacks all
over the world, all over the country and all
over the world.
My instinct is never to do this.
If there's a story that I want to cover, I
cover the story.
But I will be very honest with you, the degree
of anti-Semitism that we've received across
all platforms over the last two weeks, just
for my coverage of the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict without actually talking about anti-Semitism
really has been insane.
We have had to ban hundreds and hundreds of
people across our platforms from everything
from calling me a Jew rat to people saying
blow up all Jews, blow up Israel, which I
consider to be just as unproductive as those
people who claim that the pro Israeli side
wants to blow up all Palestinians.
Like it's it's just as disgusting.
And I did something that I don't feel great
about, which is I didn't do a story that I
wanted to do since last week.
I wanted to do a story about how criticism
of the Israeli government and foreign policy,
which is valid and in which I participate
myself and have for a long time that has become
a cover for fuel, for an opening, for just
outand out anti-Semitism and even physical
violence against random Jewish people or people
believed to be Jewish out on the streets.
Normally, I'd be telling you, but I haven't
about all of these different things.
And yesterday I tweeted, If I'm completely
honest, I hesitate to do a segment covering
the anti-Semitic attacks and beatings of the
last week because I don't have the stomach
for the deluge of anti-Semitism that such
a segment would trigger against me.
Even the responses to that tweet were filled
with anti-Semitic comments, which immediately
led to me just blocking a whole bunch of people.
And I'm not going to highlight any of those
messages today, but I've decided to talk about
this today, partially because of some of the
positive responses I received and also because
it's already not being talked about enough.
As I see coverage of this issue, the the anti-Semitic
attacks are already not getting enough coverage.
And if I don't talk about it, I'm hoping for
it to be erased.
And I can't do that now.
For some reason, there are some on the left
who do not talk about anti-Semitism either
because they believe it conflicts with their
views about Israeli foreign policy, which
is a different topic.
Israeli foreign policy and anti-Semitism are
two different topics, unless you only talk
about the former to hide the latter.
But that's a very specific case.
Some on the left don't talk about anti-Semitism
because they see Jewish Americans as an elite
privileged group, which in and of itself is
actually based on an anti-Semitic trope.
So I know that this is going to be a mess.
I know we'll have to block another few hundred
people, but we have to talk about what's been
going on.
For example, three men went to a synagogue
in New York City, made anti-Semitic comments
to just four dudes hanging out outside and
vandalized the synagogue.
A synagogue in Chicago has been vandalized.
Thursday night.
A random Jewish man in New York City's Times
Square was beaten up just in the middle of
the street, a beating.
Twenty nine year old with a yarmulke in New
York City assaulted by a violent mob called
a filthy Jew, a dirty Jew saying Hamas will
kill all of you and Israel will burn guys.
That's not a criticism of Israeli foreign
policy.
That's anti-Semitism.
In Los Angeles, a group of people went to
a sushi restaurant and shouted anti Israeli
comments at people they believed to be Jews
while brandishing a deadly weapon in Bal Harbor,
Bal Harbor, Florida.
Eric Organ said he was walking with his family
with with his while vacationing.
When four men in an SUV began yelling anti-Semitic
comments, Oregon was wearing a yarmulke.
The men shouted Free Palestine and Die Jew,
as well as threats to rape his wife and daughter.
They.
Garbage at the family feces has been left
outside of a synagogue, another man torched
a Jewish community center.
Synagogues in some places are now hiring armed
security.
I could go on, but it's not necessary because
the big picture is that officials say hate
crimes against Jews are growing dramatically
in the aftermath of the recent Israeli-Palestinian
flare up and violence.
We are witnessing a dangerous and drastic
surge in anti Jewish hate, said the head of
the Anti Defamation League.
The Anti Defamation League has identified
one hundred and ninety three reports of anti
Jewish incidents in the last week.
One hundred and thirty five reports the week
before.
And the point here is, and I really wish that
some of the anti Israeli people understood
this, when Israel does something and Jews
around the world, many of whom have never
been to Israel, most of whom have never been
to Israel, are attacked on the streets, it
makes more and more people say, wow, I might
have to move to Israel someday.
I hope people understand this.
If you really want to help make progress on
the Israeli-Palestinian conflict and get more
people on your side like me fighting for a
safe and fair situation for Israelis and Palestinians,
lifting the blockade, stopping the settlements,
getting leaders on both sides that actually
care about the people in a real way.
Right.
Don't do stuff that makes Jewish people say
holy, it's insane out there.
I might need to move to Israel to feel safe.
This is the great conundrum.
The more of this stuff that goes on, the more
people will say, I don't care what Israel
does because I might need to flee there someday.
And we saw this in Europe as anti-Semitism
exploded under Trump, do not because of Trump,
but during the Trump era, we saw the far right
nationalist movements in Europe and anti-Semitism,
the desire to move to Israel for safety went
up.
So the best thing that these people can do,
if they can put their anti-Semitism on hold
for a second is don't make random Jews around
the world feel unsafe.
Don't make Jews on the streets of New York
City feel so unsafe that they say I might
have to move to Israel to be safe.
OK, so it's an incredible conundrum and so
counterproductive and obviously toxic and
disgusting.
So, listen, I know what a lot of the reaction
will be to me doing the segment, but I can't
not say anything about it.
Let me know your thoughts, you can find me
on Twitter at Pakman.
Monday, Memorial Day, we're doing a one day
membership special, I would love for you to
sign up today at Join Pakman Dotcom, but if
you want to wait for just an insanely crazy
coupon code to get a big discount off of membership,
Monday, Memorial Day is the day we'll be sending
out our newsletter on Monday morning with
a incredibly I mean, I would call it an immoral
coupon code.
It's that cheap.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com
and you'll be notified Monday morning.